aujourd'hui macao est sorti de son
enclos il a la chance de pouvoir courir
avec wonder woman les gros lobby comme
ça les gens ont peur j'attends donc moi
je suis là chaque année pour sortir les
gros le duo participe à la 10e édition
du canicross du refuge spa de plaisir
une centaine de chiens
certains du refuge certains avec leurs
maîtres et de toutes tailles et au
départ dans la forêt de sainte apolline
et ça va le faire parce qu'il aime bien
être toujours en premier donc c'est
toujours une chien c'est vraiment de
très bons moments passés avec mon chat
les très grands complicité pour cette
course anniversaire des étudiantes de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines ont participé aux projets de
cette association qui leur tenait à
coeur la ressource de partenariat pour
la collation pour les médailles et aussi
au niveau tout ce qui est communication
sur l'événement richard de bénévoles et
c'est un parcours de 5 km avec des
gamelles de ravitaillement bien
nécessaire et une ligne d'arrivée
méritée pour les canidés maîtres et
chiens sont fiers de poser sur un dogue
walk imaginé pour l'occasion on a des
chiens craintif qui ont couru et une
fois qu'ils courent ils oublient tout
don qui sont à fond dans la course et
avec leurs maîtres
donc ça leur fait oublier leur peur donc
voilà c'est pour tout ça que le sport
avec un chien peut apporter énormément
si la ventura ci pas de vous a plu il
existe une fédération des sports et
loisirs canins avec plus de 100 clubs en
france dont un à coignières